le salon de l'épicerie fine porte de
versailles à paris attire chaque année
près de 4000 visiteurs
pas moins de 370 exposants pour
l'édition 2010 9 81% français 20%
d'autres pays européens
parmi eux une dizaine de pme
bourguignonne comme la maison toussaint
installé à are ce lot sa présence tous
les ans depuis six ans à ce salon est
cruciale al'approche défaite
les revendeurs sont déjà à la recherche
des produits pour noël l'un des
spécialités comme le gâteau au miel et
aux épices toussaint qu'on vend toute
l'année et ensuite on fait des packaging
spécifique à noël en jeu tout aussi
important pour cet autre biscuiterie de
semur en auxois qui n'a que 5 ans
d'existence toute première participation
au salon pour les eaux minérales de
villemain froid qui à vesoul en
haute-saône emploie une vingtaine de
personnes ça fait maintenant trois ans
qu'on est sur le marché français et
international
on n'est pas encore bien connus de ces
institutions bon le fait d'être là bas
ça a confirmé ça nous faisait beaucoup
développée parmi les plus anciennes
maisons bourguignonne la famille perono
et la tradition tient sa place dans les
casses triffin on veut aussi démontrer
la qualité de nos miel à travers notre
histoire familiale vieille de cinq
générations de producteurs apiculteurs
français
réservé aux professionnels ce salon
permet aux entreprises de faire une
moisson de contrats nous les épiceries
fines
les confiseries les torréfacteurs c'est
un peu le genre de magasin qui passe ça
représente plus de 15% notre chiffre
d'affaires ne s'est pas négligeable un
véritable tremplin de visibilité et de
notoriété pour les entreprises
régionales